madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le 24
février dernier Vladimir Poutine a
engagé la Russie dans une guerre
d'agression contre son voisin ukrainien
une nouvelle phase de ce conflit c'est
ouvert le vendredi 30 septembre avec
l'annexion illégale des régions de
Kerson
zapporodia doniq et luganzk la plus
grande annexion de territoires en Europe
depuis 1945
le rassemblement national condamne cette
annexion résultant de scrutin ne
correspondant pas aux standard
démocratique les plus élémentaires et
organisés en zone de guerre
le droit des peuples a disposer de même
ne doit en aucun cas se transformer en
armes politique au militaire toute notre
solidarité va au peuple ukrainien nous
réaffirmons notre attachement au respect
des règles qui doivent régir le concert
des nations depuis la chute du mur de
Berlin d'aucun pensait que l'histoire
était finie contrairement au
rassemblement national qui a toujours
fait preuve de réalisme politique
celle-ci revient en portant dans cette
tumulte la naïveté des élites
européennes ne pensant qu'en terme
d'accord de libre-échange d'ouverture à
la concurrence et chérissant un
multilatéralisme Béa sous protection
américaine
le monde se conjugue en rapport de force
et non pas en accord Bruxelles lois
nous avons eu tort d'oublier l'adage
romain CIVIS packem Parabellum car à la
mesure de notre impréparation la guerre
est aujourd'hui à nos portes
cette crise n'est pas conjoncturelle
elle est structurelle ce sont 30 ans
d'un curry de nos politiques de défense
diplomatiques énergétique économique et
budgétaire qui en sont à l'origine tout
d'abord un curry politique
incurie de nos politiques de défense
cela fait des années que le
rassemblement national n'a eu de cesse
d'alerter les gouvernements sur la
faiblesse des moyens alloués à notre
défense Marine Le Pen dans son projet
présidentiel proposé de porter le budget
de la défense à 55 milliards d'euros en
2027 permettant ainsi à notre pays
d'être prêt en cas de conflit de haute
intensité et d'affirmer son statut de
puissance mondiale
enfin une prise de conscience tardive
apparaît dans le projet de loi de
finances avec une augmentation du budget
de nos armées qui restent insuffisantes
pour que la France et les moyens de sa
défense un curry diplomatique aussi
Marine Le Pen a toujours soutenu les
initiatives diplomatiques de d'Emmanuel
Macron car elle correspondait à
l'intérêt national malgré les appels
incessants du président de la République
la voix de la France ne porte plus notre
position de puissance d'équilibre est
sans cesse remise en cause nos alliés
polonais et baltes ne nous font plus
confiance les Russes traitent
directement du destin de l'Europe avec
les Américains nous sommes marginalisés
au sein de l'Alliance occidentale les
initiatives diplomatiques sont désormais
sous-traités à la Turquie et à la Chine
c'est pourquoi le rassemblement national
a toujours revendiqué la place
singulière de la France dans le concert
des nations proche de nos alliés mais
non alignés nous laissant libre de
proposer une autre voie pour la paix
un curry énergétique surtout votre
gouvernement après avoir mené une
politique antinucléaire et contraint et
forcé de retrouver la raison
rattrapé par le réel vous êtes bien
obligé de reconnaître que la politique
de développement de notre parc nucléaire
défendu par Marine Le Pen et vitale
Emmanuel Macron a fermé ce Fessenheim
sous la pression de l'Allemagne mais il
reste muet face à la Belgique qui ferme
encore aujourd'hui ses réacteurs
nucléaires une baisse massive de la
production d'électricité belge mais en
danger l'ensemble du système électrique
européen déjà fragile un réseau
interconnecté européen implique une
coordination l'Europe a consciemment
affaibli le modèle français au lieu de
son inspirer si la France fait preuve de
solidarité avec ses voisins
n'acceptons pas de nous tirer une balle
dans le pied au nom des obsessions
d'idéologues antinucléaires
l'incurie économique parlons-en une
politique mondialiste nous a conduit à
perdre notre souveraineté après trois
décennies de désindustrialisation de la
France la Russie est le premier
producteur mondial de matière première
et la Chine et l'usine du monde la
France en est dépendantes la
réindustrialisation et la relocalisation
des productions est indispensable à
toute politique de puissance la guerre
en Ukraine est un révélateur
supplémentaire de la nécessité d'un
patriotisme économique les Français
l'attendent le rassemblement national le
défend le localisme est un
protectionnisme naturel qui permet de
défendre notre tissu industriel et
économique
incurie budgétaire enfin votre
gouvernement présente un budget 2023
lourdement déficitaire creusant la dette
de notre pays qui devrait atteindre les
3000 milliards d'euros
notre autonomie financière on est
durement touché et nous mène à la merci
de la montée des taux d'intérêt de la
dette française un phénomène que nous ne
contrôlons pas face à la guerre et à la
crise financière qui arrive les seules
solutions que vous nous proposez c'est
de baisser le chauffage et de mettre des
cols roulés
si les légitimes de sanctionner la
Russie il faut agir avec efficacité et
responsabilité jamais au détriment des
français tel est notre rôle le
rassemblement national défend les
sanctions ciblées sur les oligarques et
sur les exportations de bien utiliser
par l'industrie de l'armement russe
comme les semi-conducteurs elle
entravent la capacité de production
militaire de la Russie ces sanctions
fonctionnent en revanche nous ne voulons
pas de sanctions contre les Français
nous avions exprimé nos réserves sur les
sanctions énergétiques et encore une
fois nous avions raison la simple
annonce des sanctions sur l'énergie ont
provoqué une hausse du cours des
hydrocarbures permettant même à la
Russie d'augmenter ses bénéfices
ces sanctions sont contre-productives et
vous voudriez continuer avec des
sanctions sur le gaz ne l'oublions pas
ces matières premières sont
indispensables à l'industrie à
l'économie européenne le travail les
transports le chauffage des Français en
dépendent nous voyons tous le coût de
l'énergie augmentée dans des proportions
irraisonnables les chèques énergie ne
résoudront pas la crise cela reportera
de quelques semaines le problème mais à
quel coût mais surtout ce sont les
entreprises qui sont en danger dépend
entier de notre économie sont menacés
sidérurgie metallurgie agriculture
industrie du verre pour densité que
quelques-uns les prix de l'électricité
ou du gaz deviennent si prohibitifs que
vous obligerez les usines à fermer cet
hiver tandis que d'autres risquent de
voir leur électricité coupée pour
soulager un réseau en extrême tension
pour la septième puissance économique du
monde quelle réussite
madame la Première ministre comme vous
le savez déjà cette problématique
énergétique hypothèque toute velléité de
ressuscité notre appareil industriel le
marché européen de l'électricité est
encore une fois un mécanisme qui
pénalise la France et annule l'avantage
comparatif de notre parc nucléaire nous
députés du rassemblement national si
nous soutenons le peuple ukrainien dans
sa défense contre l'invasion russe nous
nous faisons l'écho de l'inquiétude
grandissante des Français qui demain ne
pourraient peut-être plus se chauffer
risque de voir leur entreprise mettre la
clé sous la porte ou encore perdre leur
emploi à cet égard nous ne pouvons que
regretter que la France et l'Union
européenne se soient engagée dans une
guerre gaziaire contre la Russie sans
avoir au préalable sécurisé des
approvisionnements en hydrocarbures à
des prix convenables notamment auprès
des États-Unis
par contre cela ne vous pose pas
problème d'acheter du gaz à
l'Azerbaïdjan un des pays les plus
corrompus du monde qui agresse l’arménie
dans notre indifférence
notre présidente Marine Le Pen proposait
des mécanismes pour maintenir bas les
prix des matières premières et vraiment
sanctionner les tarus et ainsi aider le
peuple craignant je vous remercie
merci beaucoup